deux rondes squeeze aujourd'hui est un
grand jour parce que je suis enfin aller
chez le coiffeur oui et rentrant chez
moi je me suis dit et si on faisait en
sorte que deux tubes heures à douzy chez
le coiffeur ouest n'ont pas forcément
besoin mais bon c'est parti on est donc
surtout qu'un seul ni sur les monnaies
fait une vidéo là dessus il ya quelques
mois et aujourd'hui on va coiffer de
youtube heures on commence tout de suite
avec mr fille regardez le il a l'air
content il est pourtant cool quoi
c'est fou il sera parfait surtout faut
pas couper la petite barbichette en bas
voilà alors qu'est ce que ça va donner
je sens que ça va être bien drôle à wii
fit mais c'est toi mr vie tu es là tu es
avec nous alors qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
de faire comme coupe en plus il vit
qu'on sait pas tout à coup de kiev qui a
tout le temps à gasquet tous abonnés
voilà je pense qu'il est un peu une
coupe comme ça sous le bonnet à ivic et
moi j'aimerais le voir avec une groupe
comme ça des poids moyens de faire une
astronome je voulais faire une affronte
c'est pas possible
obama attendait voilà on va trouver un
petit chapeau polycom voilà d'envoyer
comme ça va les cheveux sont sous le
bonnet là il est parfait et on sait
maintenant ce qui se cache sous cette
casquette des fois les petites
moustaches aussi bas pas sur cette photo
le coup valeur ajoutée shikoku remettre
ça sous sa casquette
personne ne doit être au courant voilà
c'est un peu mieux cacher voilà et
d'envoyer dans les vidéos il fait comme
ça il fait exactement comme ce qu'on
fait là ils les cachent bien des à la
casquette on dirait pas et ensuite le
soir quand ils plus en vidéo qui avec sa
copine boom
qu'est ce qui se passe en deuxième tube
heures on va coiffer siphan au bon
j'avoue j'ai fait mon de reculer sur
saône et photos je voulais pas prélever
1 photo concept à bélaye un problème
pour la boucherie gardé aucune bush ne
correspond elle est trop petite
bonjour six panneaux comment ça va alors
déjà six panneaux et les cheveux noirs
il semble au bras bon on va les faire
noir voilà c'est un petit côté obscur
avance fano il y avait une petite coupe
au bol comme moi finalement y ait du
talent la gueule dans l'air non voilà
c'est un peu comme ça à tous avant
c'était comme ça maintenant c'est comme
ça voilà un peu plus stylé et nous on va
faire le niveau supérieur comme ça mais
non mais j'arrive pas à mêler les
cheveux fins et tout donc très compliqué
à coiffer et ben voilà on arrive à un
certain style là y'a plus qu'à mettre
une petite fleur juste là et voilà quand
vous critiquez mon travail là il ya un
truc au look la belle ou même le clin
d'oeil alors là je suis obligé de vous
montrer ça j'attends une première
critique de mon talent de coiffeur
dégueulasse ah oui d'accord c'est pas
dégueulasse c'est dégueulasse rats aux
[ __ ] sexy parfait bagasse
mais qu'est-ce que vous avez des formes
et tous les mois la bourse a suffi
suivant on va dire que tout le monde
aime et voilà et non je suis pas un
dictateur c'est rien c'est ton tour
alors à sa salle a grossi
regardez il ya la présence d'un double
menton ici bas je suis désolé voilà mais
on va quand même de coiffer et c'est
cyprien avait été aux carottes des
cheveux en bas comme ça plutôt long et
agréable mais par contre sur le dessus
regardez c'est bon là ce qui se passe
normalement quelque chose sur le dessus
mais je sais pas quoi mettre je sais à
percer go mais oui c'était la touch qui
nous fallait à ces parfaits attention
j'attends qu'il bouge un peu
oh oui oh oui c'est magnifique moyen qui
vient de se faire percer qu'il a encore
mal le nouveau style de monsieur dream
wahou bg moi je dis voilà quelqu'un qui
a du goût très chic il est vachement
plus sexy en roux cyprien la vachette je
t'épouse alors là c'est unanime tout va
qu'il fait j'appelle à la barre bob
lennon
il nous vient du gaming à on reconnaît
un peu mais mais pas du tout aussi
comment il a beaucoup de cheveux mauves
lennon si on lui faisait la coupe aph
amp tard qui est finalement plutôt
simple à faire et voilà on a
l'impression de voir un véritable mix
des deux youtuber on a créé youtuber si
ça c'est pas fou à l'est la petite photo
ce fut rapide mais efficace
hop là et en plus on a le clin d'oeil
mais que demande le peuple
fanta les verts on est à nous j'appelle
à la barre le binôme de bob les nomme
fanta et du coup en temps voulu faire la
coupe de bob
bon déjà je trouve son visage est décalé
un peu il ya un problème et un pôle
chirurgie à faire mais bon moi je paye
chirurgien du coiffeur
voici la vraie coupe de fanta et si on
lui fait la coupe de bob
on voit bien qu'il ya un problème là
cette mèche on dirait une griffe
carrément sexy forme tard c'est nickel
ça à l'anpe clin d'oeil à la on
al'impression on a besoin qui fait la
gueule à sa maman qui a pu lui acheter
un truc là mais ne t'en fais pas tu
l'auras skylanders mon petit fond de
teint j'appelle à la barre
norman avec une tache sur le front sais
pas pourquoi alors normalement norman
possède des bouclettes violente mais ça
la grosse iv pourquoi ça grossit tous
les youtuber c'est dingue ça ils veulent
qu'on vienne obèses c'est ça voilà sa
coupe de d'habitude un peu pour les
boucles à son plus joli et normalement
et si norman était une racaille
mesdames et messieurs attention tours de
magie par la norme à j-6 boyoud la
casquette
wesh wesh you à des lunettes cassées
voilà comme s'il venait de se battre hop
non non on ferme pas les yeux c'est le
flash c'est ça à temps je retire voilà
mais il fait refaire mon camp les yeux
mais il a un problème mais moi je vous
le petit clin d'oeil aux amateurs un
caprice comme fanta
j'appelle à la barre le youtube eure nat
ou une youtube buzz j'ai pris la plus
belle photo que j'ai trouvé chez ces
jurés bas croyez moi enfin je veux dire
ça se voit quand même
il y aura un morceau de pain sont sais
pas pourquoi mais bon attention le
résultat est
j'ai l'impression de te voir jouer comme
l ai regardé ce pinceau quoi il est il a
agrippé à son nez on sait pas pourquoi
quelqu'un on pourrait faire un atout en
plus à des beaux cheveux longs de filles
et là on lui a fait la bonne copie nul
de polnareff je sais qu'elle couvrait de
coeur à tous en mai à temps mais ça me
fait peur - quand les yeux deviennent
blancs comme ça je sais quoi lui faire
natu la licorne par contre c'est lui
faire un front de huit mètres et demi
heure sur la photo une belle petite
licorne
regardez même elle allait elle a l'air
étonné de la coupe de l'uefa elle était
aussi étonné juste de mettre les pieds
dans le salon magnifique un petit clin
d'oeil
non juste une tête choquer mais non non
non non non non là c'est pas un casting
pour the walking dead
alors vous en pensez quoi trois petits
points ça veut dire quoi se dire que
j'adore attend en plus trois petits
points mais quelle est cette photo de
profil monsieur comment peux-tu te
permettre de juger mon travail quand ta
photo c'est saana tout a répondu avec un
pinceau en lévitation sur son nez oui
mais ça n'a tout c'est un petit style
c'est la main d'hockey effet les trucs
bizarres dans la mode et là c'est la
mode voilà moi c'est pas le pinson
lévitation sur le nez c'est le [ __ ] tu
comprends ce que je veux dire natubu à
l'esprit tout à la mode et ça sera
jamais j'appelle à la barre antoine
daniel moi j'ai probablement choisi la
photo la plus dépressif de lui mais bon
moment voulaient pas au web assez c'est
l'un des mieux fait aussi que je dise à
chaque fois que c'est super chiant il me
fait confiance
elles ne seront pas moi je trouve que
c'est bien sûr un petit côté mystérieux
et où on voit pas totalement ses yeux ça
c'est un truc qui fait craquer les
filles je suis désolé regardez le bien
c'est heureusement là c'est vrai que ça
fait peut-être craquer aucune fille à te
faire que faire
et si on fait la coupe moustache mais
des moustaches partout comme ça et voilà
j'ai terminé alors ça c'est neuf radars
un alley-oop la petite photo ah on a le
clin d'oeil en plus voilà qu'on me dit
qu'on a innové même l'huile est d'accord
antoine daniel et moustache désormais
j'appelle à la barre mathieu sommet at
on rappelé à lui léguer grand copain
antoine daniel j'ai aussi une photo
vraiment charmante
j'ai déjà une idée pour mathieu et voilà
la coupe n'est salle fallait en plein
donné comme ça aux enfants de cheveux
fins en forme de cheveux voilà bien un
petit style quand même c'est fantastique
j'appelle maintenant la barre enjoy
phoenix et une youtube beauté en énorme
il s'est carrément bien anne on l'a cru
station un peu dégueu on voit des vrais
cheveux à l comment on va faire david si
enjoy phoenix avait les cheveux courts
et après un petit air de jennifer lauret
cela a quelque part genre par exemple à
côté d'eux se peignent la non bon enjoy
stewart
voici en photos sur lesquelles je me
suis appuyé regardez bien les
ressemblances regardez les bien y en a
pas tant que ça j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu
[ __ ] c'est bon c'est la première
cliente mécontente soit pas en faire
tout un plat attend l appellation
mécontent non plus sur la photo finale 1
lalart même plutôt contente garder la
bouche comme ça il est temps d'en finir
j'appelle à la barre joueur du grenier
il a des cheveux un tout petit peu
boucle et qui tourne tout petit peu
source on frôla je pense qu'on va
carrément révolutionner le genre à avoir
cette coupe qui fait car dans flipper
aurait juste ses deux yeux de parts et
d'autres joueurs du alexandra ledermann
et voilà les gens le salon ferme ses
portes à lyon n'a qu' homme coiffé au
moins dix clients en une journée ce qui
est pitoyable je sais ça vous a plu si
c'est le cas comme d'habitude n'hésitez
pas à mais la vidéo ou alors à aller
chez le coiffeur et a demandé la cour
ustache merci d'avoir regardé comme
d'habitude on se retrouve très vite dans
une nouvelle vidéo chat monde pis
[Musique]